most cringe-worthy moment and there is
there's more came from Bill Clinton
himself I know you're surprised here's
what he said about his affair with
Monica Lewinsky you feel like you're
staggering around you've been in that 15
round prize fight it was extended to 30
rounds and here's some will take your
mind off it for two oh wow that's what
happens everybody's life has pressures
and disappointments and terrors fears of
whatever things I did to manage my
anxieties for years Wow right it just
never ends joining me now is a woman you
know Juanita Broderick one of Bill
Clinton's accusers you know it's
fascinated wanting to thank you for
joining me tonight I appreciate it
in 2004 when he was promoting his
biography he said the reason that he had
that affair with Monica Lewinsky and did
what he did was because he could now I'm
going to believe that answer right as
opposed to this one and you know and
even if we were to believe him that he
used a woman like a product in some way
to manage his anxiety is in and of
itself horrific but he sounds almost as
though he's he's making an excuse that
he thinks people are going to appreciate
oh I know I do when I first heard about
that Tammy I tweeted I said what in
heaven's name is going on you don't
we'll the next episode talked about the
women that he raped the rim the women
that he sexually assaulted where can
they possibly go from here I I was
astounded and see this I think what's
interesting too is there may be now a
category of voters some younger people
who might not even really know the
details of his history
it's almost presented as though the
Monica Lewinsky dynamic and look I've
seen interviews with her she's a bright
woman her life of course has been
changed forever because of this but it's
almost as though he's trying to find a
new woke excuse because it's you know
and whatever it is if you're a victim in
some way or if you were acting out then
you're going to get a pass on
this but do you think Juanita that with
but you look are these things that they
really want to remind the American
people about you've been having to deal
with this for so long do you think this
is going to be helpful to them or do you
think it will hurt them no I think
people will be absolutely shocked and
you know I think about all the women
that are really right here sitting in
this chair with me tonight I think about
Kathy Shelton the young 12 year old it
was horrific ly raped and in a coma for
almost a month and Hilary provided
assistance to the rapist and got him off
I think about Kathleen Willey I think
about Paula Jones I think about Leslie
Mill we all of us with these were sexual
attacks and rapes no need for Monica I
want I want you and our viewers to hear
a little bit more about what bill said
about what happened to a Miss Lewinsky
after everything came out take a listen
to this yeah I feel terrible about the
fact that Monica was his life was
defined by it unfairly I think you know
over the years I've watched her trying
to get a normal life back again yeah you
know it's still no real apology he feels
bad about that do you do you think he
feels the same about you oh he doesn't
feel bad about any of this
he just wants sympathy from people and
and he didn't write this let me tell you
who wrote this
Hillary wrote this she doesn't want him
to go anywhere near that there might
have been feelings for Monica Lewinsky
she was just a toy yeah you know I'll
tell you why Nita it's when it comes to
the human condition and so many women
have had of course an experience of
either sexual harassment of or sexual
violence the reminder of this I now also
trying to escape the me to movement but
it's a remarkable thing that this is
something that that both of them would
feel comfortable reminding people of and
parading back out as though this is
somehow their claim to fame or they
still have absolutely no problem in so
many ways when it comes to the vibes
that they've impacted it does seem
though
to be an effort to remake themselves or
to at least tell a new generation that
they're not to be blamed for anything
yeah I you know to me it was absolutely
unreal when I heard about it that Hulu
could support this lowlife sexual
predator and come out with this nonsense
it was a very disgusting and despicable
thing well the good news is Juanita were
reminded all the time about what not to
become that's what they've provided to
us thank you for joining me tonight I
appreciate it